she's one last quick example before I
show you you saw one of the mysteries
that I introduced a week or two ago what
about if we do something like a lighter
noon 8 c 8 so I know what row I want I
know what odds are I should expect as
well right because it's it's an MCN
right but let's just see how it works
out what's on the new rail n factorial
then the next thing comes is our
factorial which is also hey now hold on
remember we said see these guys they add
up to em and then these guys they add up
to and well therefore what's going to
have to round this out well it's your
factorial isn't it
hold on a second hold on you know who
what this term is supposed to be you
have it on your triangle what is the
term it's one this cancels with this
naturally so therefore you see it's not
just a cute trick that zero factorial is
1 by division remember we reverse
engineered it it has to be 1 otherwise
the whole Pascal's triangle just
explodes
ok so there's another reason why and as
you confirmed in cm in this case where n
is 8 it's on the answer
okay now this is going to be my
mechanism for explaining what a
mysteries are that introduced before so
I'm gonna leave this here if you haven't
got a reason don't panic I won't rub it
off but I just need to cover it for a
second yeah you've already got your
customers triangle in front of you but
you probably haven't got this part of it
highlighted but I wonder how many of you
actually remember me pointing out this
particular pattern in Pascal's triangle
it's very weird I've picked out some of
the rows can anyone work out why I
picked these rows what's special about
these rooms
yeah okay this thing birthplace but hold
on a second I think in Pascal's triangle
all rooms are the same weight right
they've all about that symmetry about
them okay there's something even more
special let me give you a hint how to
look at the first number I've circled on
each row but what are those numbers 2 3
5 7 you skipper for you I'm only
highlighting the prime numbers okay do
you remember when I highlighted this
pattern to you notice your calculator
there right if you have a look at any of
the rows that I've highlighted second or
third row 5th through 7th row in these
rows and only in these rows all the
subsequent numbers you get all the 13
see 113 233 etc go ahead and try them on
your calculator they're all divisible by
13 these guys are all divisible by 11
these guys are all divisible by 7 ok now
I have pointed that out to you and maybe
it's sort of scared past you can you
thought that's we don't get it
no questions to do it good one okay I'm
gonna explain to you why this is
we've done some examples already right
let me just put this up again I'll come
back to it we've done some exams right
right I want you to have a look at them
closely and let's put a few beside it so
you can see what's going on okay we did
say 75 this okay let's add another one
down the bottom here let's do this look
at the sixth row you look at the sixth
row with me you've got there on your own
your triangle do you notice none of the
terms a lot I think it's six 15 2015 16
tetra is that the one with you yeah
none of them endo visible by six do you
see that like they're almost but not
quite
let's see why if I do say 60 63 let's go
back to this some factorial notation way
of writing this binomial coefficient and
try and sort of get at the keys of
what's happening by definition I'm
saying you've got your n factorial at
the top help me out what's gonna happen
number one three factorial 3 factorial
okay
now I've written a spicy barbecue going
so you can keep going down the page from
here I can again do that unrolling thing
right I can say well that's gonna be on
the top six times five times four times
over and I stop there because this is a
point that's useful to me it's like it's
not there on the denominator I've got
the 3 factorial already I know that's
gonna cancel this other 3 factorial
though I think I need to unroll that as
well so I can start to cancel it - it's
alright free and
and one okay so far so good I haven't
done anything you know rocket science
I'm just expanded that the according to
what we know I've got definite
definitions there's some Catholic we
already know about this so that's the
easy part
what else can we cancel yeah yeah
fantastic you can see and then those
guys gonna go aren't they okay so
therefore a lot of this collapses what
do you get left with on the numerator
you get that freakin twenty there what's
left on the denominator one so those all
those things sort of have vanished away
and that of course is the middle term
isn't now just think about what's
happened to you
why isn't this a multiple of six because
I started off the very first thing that
I wrote was six times some other stuff
but then what I ended up with was not a
multiple of six what at which point did
stop becoming a multiple see I cancelled
a few different things when I cancel
these two was it still a multiple of six
it was right because look there's a six
right there okay but then the next thing
that Rick suggested was I canceled that
six with these guys which is absolutely
right so that six goes you just get one
with a five in the four and of course
neither of them are going to make you a
multiple of six does that make sense
okay now I can do this for any other
term in that row in fact I'll do it one
more time just so you see and I
convinced them what's happening if I do
the next one along 64 come on you can
tell me what's right now what's on the
top exactly so again you're starting
that that thing says six times five
times this other stuff you're expecting
something should be a multiple six but
what's on the denominator anyone
for factorial 2 factorial because of
course those two add up to n which is 6
this time ok all right
what now I'm gonna I'm gonna unroll that
thing
ok this guy up here I can pull the
fourth factorial out so 6 times 5 times
4 factorial and that full factorial is
there ready to be cancelled
ok what's gonna happen very very similar
pattern right you still get this guy
that goes just like before and then
you're looking you see are there any
other options in the answers yes
this guy is gonna turn this into a 3 do
you agree it's like oh no multiple six
anymore which is why we got 3 times 5
which is as you can check on your trike
now just look at what we've concluded on
these rows where our cool weird pattern
doesn't work the reason doesn't work is
because something will always catch you
right it's like a multiple 6 and 106 yet
not anymore
someone always will get you down the
bottom does that make sense now just
have a look at a turn on the next row
anyroad
sorry any term like say this guy who
already worked up this one right it's in
the seventh row why is it so important
to me because 7 is prime okay
now have a look at what happened look
the first thing I wrote down was you
know six factorial six that whatever
seven factorial I'm like cool I started
off on a multiple of seven or six of
eight but eventually some things cancel
out right but this seven doesn't cancel
in fact it Clark it's have a look let me
just do the next totally you won't even
have to calculate this one let's do
seven see four that's seven factorial
for three you with me so far seven six
five three two one because my four
factorials of cancel do you see
nothing's gonna touch at seven do you
see and do you see why nothing can touch
the seven because it's prime why
literally means nothing divides by here
that's what prime means right the only
thing that could divide by seven is like
seven or like another multiple of seven
okay but have a look what's the biggest
number that's in your fraction it's all
if this guy isn't it write the
denominator never has a bigger number
the numerator always has the biggest one
okay so there's no can look at me any
sevens down here so there will be
nothing to divide through by that seven
and it's the same whichever whichever of
the prime Rose that you're on right
these guys are going to be like what's
that 11 factorial on what for this one
this will be 1 factorial 10 factorial
right and then this one will be 11
factorial on two factorial n factorial
and you'll never get an 11 on the
denominator it cancel out all the 11s
you have on the numerator
the same for the thirteens and the same
for the 17th and on okay does it make
sense do you see why we needed this
machinery in period 7 0 Allah to
understand what was actually doing ok so
it's a bit of a mystery solved
I haven't yet and rewards for another
little while explain why I'm so that
explain why the whole Milla is this a
promise we'll get to it ok but at least
for now as we just demonstrated it very
Abele we can do
ok